eine unschuldige studentin ein
milliardär mit schattenseiten
eine sadomaso geschichte von
unterwerfung und dominanz 50 shades of
grey jetzt auch als film
das
weltweit ein kassenschlager mit
begeisterten fans die kritik war weniger
euphorisch die story ein kitschiger
aschenbrödel aufguss die sexszenen
harmloser mutti planung
schützenhilfe kommt dagegen von der
weltweit renommierten soziologin eva
illouz
der sadomaso bestseller zeigen
lösungswege für moderne
beziehungskonflikte sagt sie natürlich
nehmen wir es für gegeben dass die
befreite sexualität eine gute sache ist
aber sie ist nicht nur befreit sie ist
zur definition dessen geworden was eine
gute beziehung zu sein hat vieles in
unserer kultur behauptet dass eine gute
beziehung von gutem sex die soziologin
liest 50 shades of grey als neue liebes
ordnung also ein sex ratgeber und so
haben manche zuschauer auch den film
verstanden
alles was in der hardcore romanze
passiert kreist um die zentralen fragen
welche bedeutung hat erfüllter sex für
eine gute zweierbeziehung und wir
erreichen die routen sex
was wir mündigkeit nennen oder
emotionale ausgeglichenheit ist sehr
stark geprägt von dem ideal der
unabhängigkeit
wir wollen nicht von anderen abhängig
sein andererseits geht es aber in einer
liebesbeziehung gerade darum abhängig zu
machen
deshalb ist die entscheidende und
schwierigste frage in liebesbeziehungen
wann geben wir unsere unabhängigkeit auf
die heldin anastacia stil unterschreibt
den unterwerfung vertrag nicht gibt ihre
unabhängigkeit also nicht auf
aber sie unterwirft sich freiwillig
seinen sexuellen rollenspiels
aber 46 alles in allem ist sehr kritik
zu verwandten also die machtspiele dass
man sich sogar gesichter von abwanderung
spiel interessant ist dass marie
caroline schriftlich und sie auch wieder
verlässt wie ein teil blieb natürlich
auch in der öffentlichkeit bleibt das
klassische rollenbild
very clear relationship sie haben diese
sehr klare beziehungen der wir genau
wissen wer die schmerzen erduldet und
wer sie zu fügt aber sie tun es für ihr
liebesleben ihre emanzipation und ihr
vergnügen auf eine gewisse art und weise
schafft das sadomaso verhältnis eine
klare rollenverteilung die wir in
modernen beziehungen heute nicht mehr
haben
ich denke deshalb ist diese geschichte
so erfolgreich geborgenheit in fesseln
dass sexuelle rollenspiel als
kompensation der gleichberechtigung ein
erfolgsrezept
zumindest auf dem buchmarkt und im kino